ام غان حوض مرحبا بكم في
البرنامج شكرا لكم لقد صدمت جيدا دعني
أسألك ماذا صنعت من اه ييد اه ش ش
آسف ماذا استفدت
من خروجها والحديث عن
محنتها ما رأيك قالت ذلك  لقد
كانت مثيرة للاهتمام بالنسبة لك كمفاوض
وكشخص تعرفه ويريد أن
يعرف قدر الإمكان عما
اختبروه جيدًا وأعتقد أن ما
قالته هو انعكاس لما
قاله جلعاد شاليط أيضًا على
انفراد عندما كان  أطلق سراحه أن
حماس كان لديها قواعد كانت تلتزم بها في
احتجاز الرهائن على عكس ما
فعلته في المجتمعات المدنية.
على سبيل المثال، ظل شالد في
الأسر لمدة خمس سنوات وأربعة أشهر
مع نفس الأشخاص الأربعة الذين كانوا
يعيشون معه طوال المحنة
التي  لقد مر بها، وهذا
انعكاس لما سمعناه منها،
كما أنها لم تتعرض للإيذاء الجسدي
بالطبع، لقد كانت محنة مؤلمة للغاية
بالنسبة لها ولا ينبغي لأحد أن يمر بذلك،
وأعتقد أن الكلمة يجب أن
تكون قليلاً  مطمئن بعض الشيء
لعائلات الرهائن الـ 220 الذين بقوا
في الخلف ولكن لا يزال هناك
سبب كبير للقلق لأنه ليس من
الواضح على الإطلاق أن حماس تحتجز جميع
الرهائن نعلم أن الجهاد الإسلامي أخذ
رهائن والجبهة الشعبية لتحرير فلسطين وأفراد آخرين
وأه رأينا السلوك  لقد حدث ذلك
داخل المجتمعات المدنية
وفي مهرجان الموسيقى والرقص
حيث وقعت مذبحة ارتكبتها
حماس لذا تعلم أنها خرجت بعد
هذه المحنة الفظيعة وهي
تتحدث لذا قالت على سبيل المثال سنلعب
بعضًا من  مقاطع صوتها
وأريد تشغيلها على التوالي لأنها
قصيرة جدًا، فإليك
كيف تصف ما رأته وأين
كانت وكيف تم
علاجها، هناك
شبكة ضخمة من الأنفاق تحتها تبدو
مثل
شبكة العنكبوت، أغلق الطبيب الذي يأتي لرؤيتنا
كل يومين أو ثلاثة أيام،
أخذ المسعف الأمر على عاتقه واهتم
بالأدوية، إذا لم تكن هناك
أدوية، كانوا يحضرون
أدوية بديلة مكافئة للأدوية،
لذلك وصف شبكة العنكبوت أولاً وأتساءل عما
إذا كان هذا خبرًا  لك أو هل كنت على
علم بذلك أم، وبعد ذلك بالطبع
تقول أنك تعلم أنها عوملت بشكل جيد
كما قلت أن الآخرين كانوا أيضًا في
تجربتك، أعتقد أنهم
عملة، فهم بالتأكيد عملة، وقد
تم تسمية شبكة الأنفاق العنكبوتية
بواسطة إسرائيل شبكة مترو كاملة
بالكامل تحت قطاع غزة،
وهذا يعكس
الواقع في غزة على مدى السنوات الـ 17 الماضية،
حيث حكمت حماس أنهم
استثمروا مبلغًا ضخمًا من المال في
الأنفاق والمخابئ تحت الأرض بينما
لم يفعلوا ذلك.  لا نستثمر نفس المبلغ من
المال في رفاهية الأشخاص الذين
يعيشون هناك، ولسوء الحظ إذا
فعلوا ذلك، فربما كان لدينا
واقع مختلف اليوم، لكنني أعتقد أيضًا أن
الرسالة الأوسع نطاقًا والتي تتابع
رسالة الملكة آر هي ذلك
لا ينبغي أن يكون مفاجئًا لأي شخص أننا
وصلنا إلى مثل هذا
الوضع المروع، بل يجب أن يكون بمثابة دعوة للاستيقاظ
لإسرائيل، حيث لا يمكنك إبقاء
شعب آخر محتلًا لمدة 56 عامًا، وتتوقع
أن يكون هناك سلام، ولا يمكنك حبس مليوني شخص.
الناس في سجن مفتوح ويتوقعون
أن يكون هناك هدوء وبالنسبة
للفلسطينيين يجب أن يكون ذلك بمثابة دعوة للاستيقاظ
إذا كنت تدعم القادة المتعصبين المتطرفين
في وأه ترفض
الاعتراف بأن الأشخاص الآخرين الذين يعيشون في
أرضك يتمتعون بنفس الحقوق التي
تتمتع بها  افعل إذن، ستعاني،
فهذه هي الأحداث الأكثر صدمة
لإسرائيل وفلسطين منذ عام 1948،
والأمل الوحيد هو أيضًا في كلمات
كين آر أن تكون لدينا لحظة استيقاظ في
نهاية هذه المأساة التي أسميها اليوم
بعد غد لأن الغد سيكون
مبكرًا جدًا لاستخلاص هذا النوع من
الاستنتاجات ولكن من الواضح أن
الأشخاص الذين أوصلونا إلى هنا،
يجب على قادتنا على كلا الجانبين الرحيل، نحن بحاجة إلى
جيل جديد برؤية جديدة
وآمل أن تزول الصدمة.  لا يمنعنا
من التطلع إلى الأمام، فلا شك في
أننا سوف نتذكر ذلك، لأنه سيصبح
جزءًا من سردنا، وسيستمر كل طرف في
إلقاء اللوم على الآخر بسبب ذلك،
لكننا كإسرائيليين وفلسطينيين
بحاجة إلى أن نتعلم أنه يتعين علينا أن نتطلع إلى الأمام،
وليس فقط  إلى الوراء،
لن يتغير تاريخنا أبدًا،
لدينا فرصة للتغيير في مستقبلنا،
لذا أريد أن أسألك لأنك
تعرفهم وقد كتبت حتى أنني
ليس لدي أي تفويض رسمي
كمفاوض ولكن على حد علمي أنا
الوحيد  مواطن إسرائيلي لديه اتصالات
مع كل من قيادة حماس
وقيادة إسرائيل، وهذا في حد ذاته
شيء غير عادي نظرًا
لحجم
الاتصال السلبي الذي لديك،
فماذا تقول لشعب حماس
أنك  أعرف هل أنت على اتصال
بهم؟ لقد أجريت محادثات عميقة
معهم، وبعض
المحادثات الصعبة للغاية، وأظل أؤكد لهم
أنه بغض النظر عما فعلوه، فإنهم
بحاجة الآن إلى فعل الشيء الصحيح والشيء
الصحيح هو إطلاق سراح المدنيين
الرهائن كما قالت الملكة ر والملك
عبد الله إنه مخالف للقرآن، ومن
المخالف للإسلام احتجاز النساء والأطفال وكبار
السن والمرضى كرهائن، فهم
بحاجة إلى فعل الشيء الصحيح الآن، ما
أفهمه هو أن هناك اقتراحًا قيد المناقشة تم
إرساله إلى  إسرائيل من حماس من قبل
القطريين والمصريين متورطون أيضًا
ويبدو أن هناك عرقلة أمام المضي
قدمًا في وقف إطلاق النار الإسرائيلي
مقابل إطلاق سراح
الرهائن المدنيين وفقًا لصحيفة وول ستريت
جورنال.
الحصار لا ترغب إسرائيل في
تأجيج آلة الحرب التابعة لحماس،
لكن لدينا أزمة إنسانية مدنية
ذات أبعاد لا تصدق،
ستتوقف المستشفيات عن العمل،
ستتوقف الكهرباء عن توفير
الرعاية المنقذة للحياة للناس، ونحن بحاجة
إلى إيجاد حل  الحل، هذه
مشكلة غبية تمنع
إطلاق سراح محتمل للمدنيين ووقف إطلاق النار
الذي من شأنه أن يسمح للناس في غزة
بالتنفس لأول مرة منذ أسبوعين،
ونحن بحاجة إلى إيجاد حل لماذا لا يستطيع
الصليب الأحمر الدولي أو قطر
الذين  اطرح هذا الاقتراح
أو يقول المصريون لإسرائيل إننا
سنرافق شاحنات الوقود F إلى غزة
وسنحضرها إلى المستشفيات
وسنضمن أن حماس لن تسرق
الوقود الذي نحتاجه لحل هذه
المشكلة الغبية من أجل تمكين الرهائن من الوصول إلى غزة.
يجب إطلاق سراحنا ومن أجل وقف إطلاق النار، ووقف
القصف على الأقل
لفترة كافية حتى يتمكن الناس من الحصول على
المساعدة في البحث عن ملجأ للعثور على مكان
للمبيت فيه طوال الليل للحصول على الطعام والماء
للشرب، علينا أن نستيقظ على حقيقة
أن  غدًا سنظل
هنا إسرائيليين وفلسطينيين
وسيتعين علينا إيجاد طريقة للعيش
معًا، نحتاج إلى إيجاد الإنسانية بداخلنا
حتى في هذه اللحظة المروعة، كما تعلم
أنك قلت الكثير من
الأشياء المهمة بشكل لا يصدق فقط  الآن، ومن
المثير للاهتمام حقًا أن نراكم تجدون
أرضية مشتركة في نقاط معينة مع
الملكة رنا لأن الانقسامات
أصبحت شديدة للغاية الآن حول من تقف إلى جانب من
تقف، وتحدثت
عن المعايير المزدوجة، لذلك
أريد ذلك  لأسألك
يبدو أن الرأي العام الإسرائيلي
بحسب الصحفيين في
إسرائيل يتحول
نحو ليس الكثير من السحق كما
قالت الحكومة حماس كأولوية أولى
ولكن إنقاذ أمر إطلاق سراح
الرهائن أه هل تعتقد أن هذا هو الحال
وتذكر أنك تفاوضت على إطلاق سراح
جلعاد شليد لنحو
1027 أسيرًا فلسطينيًا،
بعضهم عاد
وارتكب الجرائم التي حدثت في
7 أكتوبر، أعني أنها
حقًا نعم أربعة الرهائن الأربعة
الأسرى الذين أطلق سراحهم في شالو كانوا
مسؤولين عن قتل
ابن عم زوجتي الأول  قبل عام من
اختطاف شاليط، لذا فإن هذا أمر شخصي، ويصبح
شخصيًا بالنسبة لنا جميعًا.
أعتقد أنه يتعين علينا أن
نفهم أنه إذا كانت هناك
فرصة لتحرير الرهائن،
فيجب القيام بكل شيء للقيام بذلك،
وأعتقد أن الحكومة الإسرائيلية
تؤجل ذلك.  إن التوغل البري هو
انعكاس لمحاولات استخدام كل
السبل الممكنة لتحرير
الرهائن المدنيين، دعونا نواجه الأمر، فإسرائيل لديها
مسؤولية أخلاقية تجاههم لأنها
فشلت في حمايتهم،
والمسؤولية الأساسية للدولة هي
حماية مواطنيها وإسرائيل.  فشلوا
في حماية مواطني إسرائيل الذين
يعيشون على طول حدود غزة، وعليهم
مسؤولية أخلاقية لإعادتهم إلى الوطن،
نعم، لقد كان التوجيه الأساسي
منذ 7 أكتوبر للمجتمع الإسرائيلي
للحكومة في الجيش لإزالة
قدرة حماس على الحكم في  غزة
وتهديد إسرائيل، وأعتقد أن
إسرائيل ملتزمة بإنجاز هذه المهمة،
لكنني أعتقد أنك على حق تمامًا في
أن الثقل الأخلاقي
لمسؤولية الدولة في إنقاذ
الأرواح البشرية وإعادة الرهائن إلى
الوطن قد أصبح الآن على وشك الانتهاء.  الجبهة
ولا أعتقد أن ذلك سيؤجل
التوغل على الأرض إلى الأبد، لكن على
الأقل في الوقت الحالي هناك نافذة صغيرة
من الفرص مع ساعة تدق
يجب استغلالها، هل يمكنني تشغيل
مقطع فيديو له؟  لقد خلقت ضجة كبيرة كما
تعلمون في إسرائيل وهذا هو
Y عندما خرجت وكان من الواضح أن
الصليب الأحمر تحدث معها وأنت تعلم
أنها هناك واستدارت
وقدمت لفتة إنسانية
ومصافحة على ما أعتقد  شخص كان
خاطفها،
إنه مقطع فيديو لحماس قاموا
بنشره، كما تعلم تغادر
وتقول وداعًا، أفترض ما رأيك
في ذلك، ما رأيك في هذه
الإيماءة، أعتقد أولاً وقبل كل شيء أنه من
المهم معرفة من هي  هي
امرأة تطوعت لسنوات في
نقل الأطفال الفلسطينيين
وأمهاتهم وآباءهم إلى المستشفيات داخل
إسرائيل لتلقي العلاج الطبي،
وكانت عضوًا في حركة النساء من أجل السلام، وهي
أكبر حركة سلام في إسرائيل، وأيضًا
امرأة أخرى فيفيان سيلفر من الكيبوتس
كان أه كان  مختطفة ومحتجزة
كرهينة في غزة كانت من
مؤسسي وقادة حركة المرأة للسلام
وأفترض أنها تتحدث بعض العربية وربما
حاولت التواصل مع
خاطفيها وأتخيل أنه لو لا
سمح الله كنت محتجزة في غزة
لفعلت ذلك  كل فرصة لتكوين صداقات مع
الأشخاص الذين يحتجزونني لأن
حياتي على المحك، أعتقد أنه علينا أيضًا أن
نتذكر أن زوجها لا يزال
محتجزًا كرهينة في غزة، وأنها لو
خرجت وفعلت على الفور شيئًا
معاكسًا تمامًا، فربما
يعرض ذلك للخطر  حياة زوجها ولكني
أعتقد أن هذا النوع من
اللفتات الإنسانية هو المهم لإظهار أنني
أعرف صديقة أجرت بحثًا عن
الناجين من المحرقة وطرحت
السؤال لماذا يصبح بعض الناجين من المحرقة
هؤلاء الأشخاص
المعادين جدًا للعرب وغيرهم  هم في
معسكر السلام وما وجدته في إجراء مقابلات مع
العديد من الناجين من المحرقة الذين كانوا جزءًا
من معسكر السلام هو أنه كانت هناك
لحظة كانوا يمرون فيها
بالمعاناة المروعة أثناء
المحرقة حيث قام شخص ما
بلفتة إنسانية وأعطاهم أحدهم قطعة من
خبز أو أعطاهم المبيت في منزل
أو أعطاهم بطانية وتلك
اللفتات الإنسانية ما من شأنه أن
يغير نظرتهم للعالم فيما بعد
ويمكنهم من دعم السلام مع
العرب بدلا من الوقوف ضدهم